hey you know guys this is the all-new
Reuben report I am the fully upgraded
Dave Rubin and I'm super excited this
week yes we are in an all-new studio I
am joining forces with the team at riot
news and I have some riot news people
with me actually the the brains in the
heart in no particular order of riot
news I don't think that's in a
particular order
I have Molly Swenson Brynn Weezer with
me you guys were crazy enough to bring
my little operation into the riot fold
and I'm very excited we both a set I
don't even know where does that good to
you dude you you single handle work
double handedly with our mans - you guys
put this thing together it's a work in
progress
Dave we're so happy to have you here I
mean this is like a new page for riot
we're launching a whole bunch of YouTube
initiatives and a lot of great videos so
talk is an important part and you know
you're our favorite talk show host
personality YouTube star in the world so
to have you here on riot it's really
it's really exciting for us so we're
happy to build this set one of the one
of the reasons I'm really excited to be
working with you guys and being part of
riot is that you guys it's not just
about talk I've been talking a lot for
the last two years it's a lot of talk
but what riots about is news and action
so can you tell us a little bit about
yeah well we launched riot to be the
first news site that links every single
story to an action that the reader can
take so it's what's going on in the
world and what you can do about it and
that was our mandate every single piece
of content has a way to get involved
either directly or somatically and
that's carried us through to here I mean
we we launched just two and a half years
ago about and it was actually the day
that hurricane sandy hit the East Coast
so that was a very interesting moment to
prove the model of news in action and I
think that as you were saying people do
a lot of talking there's a lot of
content being generated and what does
that mean if there's nothing that you
can do to act on it yeah and I think
that's sort of why I felt like this was
we literally like I called you for
coffee like I was like let's have coffee
and then five minutes later we were like
let's do this because that's what I've
been trying to do with this show not
beat the news into people but give them
just enough so they can feel informed
and then and now that we're adding this
other part to it I know what to say
News News and news inspires you news
moves you news angers you and I think
what's you know why we built riot is
because there's been so much at that
time where you have those emotions and
then the story is over and you move on
to the next story and there's there's
nothing you can do about it you feel
helpless so we really are trying to
build something here with Ryan and and
now you're important part of that family
and that journey of trying to say here's
what's going on the world here now
here's what you can do about it so we're
so excited to have you all right good
journey
it is gonna be a good journey I hope
that this is going to become some sort
of antidote to the outrage I'm really
excited you guys are gonna be able to be
part of exactly everything that we're
doing here it's really really cool let
us know what you think what do you think
of our new set what do you think of
these - how am i doing I'm out of my
jacket right it's craziness let us know
in the comments right down below thanks
people are going absolutely bonkers over
Hillary Clinton's emails former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton has
come under fire after the New York Times
reported on allegations that she skirted
federal record-keeping laws by using her
personal email account for her work
communications as Secretary of State
currently the law requires that email
correspondences to and from federal
officials be archived in the event that
they should become the subject of an
investigation or congressional inquiry
all right so I'm conflicted about this
story because I get it you can't have a
personal server and when you're working
for the State Department you're supposed
to use their email address and all that
so I get it whatever they did here was
sort of shady on the other hand we live
in this endless outrage machine
constantly and I feel like two days from
now we'll have the next Bill Cosby story
or the next Brian Williams story we're
all gonna forget about this where does
this fall on your outrage ohmmeter very
low I mean personally for me emails like
a source of anxiety it's just other
people's to-do lists for me so I feel
for her that like she's trying to
separate I don't or not separate work
personal it's fine I just feel like if
this is the worst thing everyone can
come up with about Hillary pre-campaign
or whatever it is fine let it be I've
been looking for certainly you've had
decades to work on Hillary Clinton and
you know if Benghazi didn't stick then
it's this email thing but also I just
think that for me I mean it's a-you know
this is a sort of a silly argument her
personal emails must be archived I mean
everybody reads every email anyway
all know that from what you know snow
didn't release them yet right like
they're reading my emails right now that
reading they're watching the show
hopefully and so I just think this idea
that just because they didn't come
through a certain place and they're not
that they're not archived is is crazy
but you see that coming from the State
Department where they're now you know
saying that they're trying to find these
emails to so to me like there's
something fishy in there because you
know everything is archived somewhere
whether she's using a gmail account or a
hotmail account or State Department so I
you know I don't know I think it's
there's a story here but whether or not
it's blown up to this proportion right
so it's kind of funny when you factor in
the Snowden stuff in the NSA stuff it's
like even if she was trying to do
something shady they probably couldn't
have gotten away with something shady so
what do you make about the outrage part
of this because that's the one of the
things I really want to focus on as we
do this show is just this three day news
cycle thing they say it's a 24 hour
thing but I find out things actually
stick a little longer it's like a three
day thing where we're outraged
everyone's going crazy and tweeting
about it and then it disappears this
one's gonna disappear pretty quick right
and isn't even too early to damage her
anyway what if this was so damaging when
they've wanted to wait for another eight
months or something it's certainly not
too damaging to I was certainly not too
early to damage her I think it could if
it was like the Sony hack and you
actually uncovered her talking some
serious [ __ ] about something right that
could happen right and that may end up
happening if she has to release these
emails after this this conflict but for
now it's just the fact that they're not
quite available isn't isn't enough to
but I do think to your point you know
when we're talking about what's
important in the world right now you
know we're spending this time focusing
on meanwhile you have Isis smashing
museums full of you know priceless
antiquities and you've got the you know
the world warming up on this coast and
then there's blizzards on the East Coast
I mean there's stuff that we can be
talking about as a country that's
probably a little more salient than the
emails that she's sending I I just don't
believe that those emails can disappear
I wish that I could delete emails
personally but I know that they live
somewhere right so so to that point
though with this distraction machine
that's going on we are a news
organization why is it that when people
want to talk about the things like
what's going on with Isis and I saw that
that video where they're destroying this
priceless stuff why don't we focus more
on
and instead we focus on all this other
distractions why is the media feeding it
to us well it's like the the important
versus the interesting right I think
that a lot of things are interesting to
people and that's sort of what drives
the economy of news if someone finds
something interesting the news reports
on it whereas the interesting stuff is
is what we should be reporting on and
making it interesting enough that people
want to read it and not the other way
around right so it's like this is when
we report about this story what we talk
about is how people can get involved
there's a great nonprofit transparency
which we'll put a link to here they work
constantly with helping people have more
transparency in their government so for
us it's an opportunity where people have
the choice you're if you're outraged by
this and you think it's crazy well then
support organizations that are working
to find a solution if you're not then
you know go flip onto the next story
yeah that's right all right so there is
a link right down below that's part of
what we're gonna do here it's not just
talk
it's action to wait but final thought on
this what this is partly making me think
is that like why would anyone want to be
a politician at this point now knowing
that we all grew up in this digital
world anyone that's growing up younger
than us now everything they've ever done
every snapchat and cyberdust that's a
new one and whisper and all them it's
all gonna be there like you got to be
out of your mind right well that's the
thing too is like you'd think at this
point there have been enough case
studies of people just being brought
down by their by their digital history
that we would be more cognizant of what
we're putting online and I think
snapchat was a bit of a response to that
right kids being like oh we should be
worried about what's going on Twitter
[ __ ] you we're just gonna use snapchat
instead and you're not gonna have access
to that which of course they found out
we thought it we do yeah but I think
that you're gonna see either much more
leniency moving forwards on whatever
your digital footprint was when you were
young and dumb or you're just gonna see
ways around that right digital products
being developed that actually do keep
privacy private yeah privacy private
she's a dreamer conversation is
important though and when people when
you when you you know snapchat comes out
and says that everything disappears and
then it gets released that it does and
people should hold them accountable you
know our whisper where it's the same
thing where you say this is a big secret
and then you're selling that information
to some
yells you should hold those companies
accountable especially as if you're
building a whole product on so it's a
whole other conversation about right to
privacy right and does that even exist
and can legislation catch up with
technology ever yeah when it comes to
that I think that frankly right to
privacy is a fallacy to a certain extent
and Hillary Clinton of all people should
know that so probably you know if we do
actually uncover something crazy in
those emails like shame on her she knew
yeah yeah but I don't know if you
listened
do we have privacy I don't know we're
doing this online so we're putting this
stuff out there publicly but we have
private lives - do we have any right to
those private lives what do you think is
this hill everything gonna blow over is
this gonna take her down let us know in
the comments right down below it is
seriously expensive to be a human on
planet earth but these ten cities take
it to a whole new level I think your
cost of living is high you should try
living one of these cities the list of
the ten most expensive cities includes
Paris Oslo Zurich Sydney Melbourne
Geneva Copenhagen Hong Kong Seoul New
York and Singapore taking the top spot
the worldwide cost of living report
compares a hundred and thirty three
cities with New York City set as a
standard base for the study according to
the report a loaf of bread a bottle of
wine and a pack of cigarettes in
Singapore will set a customer back
thirty nine dollars and eleven cents all
right so we all lived in New York City
at different times in our lives was cost
one of the reasons you got the hell out
of there I don't know back when I lived
in New York City it was cheap
I lived there in 2003 I guess when you
could still live in Manhattan but you
can't live in Manhattan anymore I mean
that's just out of the question you
can't even live in Williamsburg anymore
and that's out of the question and and
now people are just moving further and
further out I'm just I'm upset that our
own Los Angeles didn't even make that
list yeah so speaking of Los Angeles
you're not you're happy it didn't make
the most expensive city was live list
seems like a really expensive city er oh
well I lived in New York my entire life
New York City the last like 10 years or
so and I moved to the LA two years ago
and I still when I go to the supermarket
or when I just buy anything or gas
whatever it is I still can't believe how
cheap it is here and I know it's not
really cheap but that's just because New
York is bonkers so when I lived in New
York I was couchsurfing
and bunk beds and like eating pizza
everyday so I was spending no money I
was an unpaid intern I and being a girl
I'm not gonna lie it's much easier to
get things for free and like drinks or
BOTS or you can go out and food as bots
bring drinks before yeah but this is not
a sustainable way that people can live
their life of just this is what I
probably hustlers do and like a
criminal's to no no I'm just saying that
you can't sort of compare the lifestyle
of somebody when is she thrived in New
York that you were trying to make well I
had a great time and I didn't end up
leaving because it was too expensive I
had opportunities elsewhere it was more
like this city is so exciting and there
are ways to get by that I found where
you weren't spending a ton of money but
I also imagine that if you're if you are
making a living or raising a family or
doing anything like that where you have
to be you have to be spending money and
not sleeping on couches then I think the
problem with these places happens when
like in New York where everybody moved
out of the city and then everybody moved
out of Williamsburg and further and
further you just lose the core of who
your artists are who at least could
afford to live down the first way what
makes the top of the list was the top
Singapore Singapore Wow
yeah are we going to Singapore can we
take the show on the road to Singapore
and maybe see what's going on I think we
should try to find out where any of them
did any of those cities shock you I mean
Paris obviously like a bunch of them
they seems Eric like these seem like
expensive places to live it was
interesting to me that so many of them
were in Asia where at the same time you
have some of the most poverty also in
the entire world and often like within
the same city it's not right I mean we
were in port-au-prince a couple of weeks
ago in City Soleil which is the poorest
neighborhood essentially in the Western
Hemisphere and this idea that you can
live there and everyone does off of an
average of what three hundred dollars a
month and like people are dancing and
people are happy and you go to New York
and you're in the subway and people are
pissed okay
depressed like it just goes to show that
how much you're making and where you're
living all that is so relative you beat
me to my final question the correlation
do you think
so you guys think there's no college
because I agree with that even I went
back to New York a couple weeks ago and
that subway thing you see these
miserable people and then it gets on you
you actually feel it versus you live in
some other cities I mean there's plenty
people that live on beaches they're
pretty happy right yeah maybe they don't
have as much money they also have to do
with the proximity to to wealth that
makes you consider your situation as
poor you know and we were talking about
this to this idea of if you don't know
that you don't have much because there's
no relative comparison to someone who
does have a lot you can maybe be happier
than if you're in a city like Singapore
or Zurich or Paris or New York where
there are the homeless and the
extraordinarily wealthy living
side-by-side that that aren't both ways
right there's there's a sense of
inequality and unfairness to that for
people on both sides yeah but it's also
in port-au-prince is just a great city
and you have all the freedoms in the
world to do whatever you want and then
in Singapore you can't even spit gum out
on the street you know so that's it
you're not gonna find the happiest
people there right sure so final thought
to your point how important is having
that artists community that that sort of
area where people can escape to to
create that's a huge part of what's
important about a city right yeah no I
think it's the most I think it's the
most important part right like you have
to have you have to have a place where
people are creating and also paying
homage to this today that they're living
in I mean that's where you find the
heart and soul of these places is always
in the artist districts and and very
rarely in the financial districts no
offense no offense there's not a lot of
creative people their creative
financially but that's about it
anyway what do you think do you guys
live in any of these 10 cities we want
to know how you're surviving over there
let us know in the comments right down
below
Millennials are drinking less coffee
thus proving that I'm not it's tea time
for us millenials according to a new
YouGov survey 42% of Americans under the
age of 30 prefer to drink tea with an
identical 42% saying they prefer coffee
further 27 percent of Millennials only
drink tea that's a huge difference from
their parents and grandparents with 70%
of Americans over the age of 65 saying
they prefer a damn fine cup of coffee
alright so first questions first
how caffeinate
are you writing this very second not
nearly enough
are you caffeine freaks I know you drink
a coffee in the morning but you're not
nearly enough
Bryn Molly won't let me drink coffee in
the morning because she says I get too
hyper and then I bounce off all the
walls and I started like yeah right you
have like a natural caffeine thing in
your brain yeah yeah but let me tell you
when I do have a coffee
yeah I have to sneak one and then I come
in and then Molly's like you drank your
coffee didn't you and then he did so
right now I have no coffee and this is
my normal sort of Stacie I wish I had
yeah now we are getting I think we're
hitting three generations here because
I'm technically Generation X now we were
discussing before you're probably
Generation Y right like that's or you
want a millennial ish what but you're
full-on millennial what's with you crazy
kids getting off the caffeine you're
drinking more tea that's what they're
telling us yeah we us didn't maybe grow
up with like all of the different types
of caffeine ways you can get caffeinated
or you got redbull
pretty girl so so far away it wasn't a
farm sorry no I think the reason we had
milk or water right really is I've never
liked the taste of coffee cause I've
always been a means to an end for me
which is the caffeine part of it so
having other options that are equally
effective to that end and it tastes
better I'm just gonna go for right he
tastes way better than coffee and if I'm
getting the same sort of caffeinated
experience from it then I'd much rather
drink something I actually enjoy well I
want to know what constitutes the tea
part because I see a lot of people in
America drinking those like giant
Arizona tea 64 ounces does that count
because that's just sugar that is pure
that's not Tencent rated evil yeah
because I don't I don't see a lot of
people on the street drinking even
Millennials drinking like a cup of fine
cup of tea I haven't seen that this
isn't Downton Abbey it's not done I
decided oh maybe that's happened but
there's like a dirty hippie Yorba mottai
crew which is like the
like that I drank a yerba mate' this
morning I died and it was given to me by
one of the kids on this staff yeah do
you great do you guys think that the tea
thing with the Millennials has something
to do with it's like a counterculture
thing to Starbucks like Starbucks became
so big it's on literally every corner
they just opened one right over here I'm
guilty of go to Starbucks all the time
too
I'm gonna see a ttle it's a brand
loyalty of mine but now when I go I'll
sometimes get coffee sometimes get tea
because honestly the coffee there isn't
great I like that bitter like grass-fed
butter coconut oil coffee you guys
alright so last thought on this just
sort of wider about Millennials in
general I feel like Millennials get a
lot of [ __ ] like everyone there's all
these articles written constantly Oh
Millennials selfie and then there's that
right there was me kind of thing but to
me I see young people at least the
people that I'm interacting with on
Twitter and on this show that they're
they're incredibly connected they're
paying attention to what's out there
they have new access to news and all the
things that we're trying to bring them
like I think they get a lot of [ __ ] do
you do you agree yeah of course but so
do you old people so but we have we have
this incredible demographic of mostly
Millennials on this overwhelming
majority on riot that are Millennials
and like I've been so blown away and
inspired and I'll be the first to defend
the generation is being connected being
socially aware being kind compassionate
caring about the other people I think
being fully aware of you know things
like bullying rights you know body image
things all of those things are we really
have people who are responding and young
people and Millennials overwhelmingly
who really want to do something and make
a difference so I say let them drink tea
I don't think I can finish it up any
cleaner than that are you a millennial
how caffeinated are you right now let us
know in the comments right down below
zombies are coming for us and they want
to eat our brains military may have its
own plan for what to do in the zombie
apocalypse comes because it will but
scientists have a different idea on how
to survive their tip head to the
mountains it would only take one day for
densely populated areas to fall to
zombies and months before zombies even
reach the northern
time zone so maybe the gang on the
walking dead had the right idea to head
to the mountains in season one all right
so I love this story because it takes
like my post-apocalyptic zombie
nightmare scenario and I watch Walking
Dead and all that and then it combines a
little science scientists looked at this
thing and said you know you could maybe
survive a little bit longer if you were
in the rural areas well thank goodness
how long would it take you to be eaten
if a zombie apocalypse Peschel if I'm
wearing these shoes when it that is that
that would be pretty good for like a
stabbing in the eye that's true that's
true if I had any karate skills maybe I
I think maybe I'm more prepared than
brin was a couple of months ago before
you got your LASIK that's part of why
you got it oh yeah you got LASIK eye
somebody told me you know cuz I had I
wore glasses before sometimes and then
somebody said that you should get LASIK
surgery in case there's a zombie attack
and you smash the last then you will be
screwed and so if I get LASIK now I
don't have to worry about having those
glasses because it'd be like I'd be that
person who'd be like I smashed my
glasses and then there's a laser right
so yeah that resonate so now I have
LASIK and like I'm totally ready in this
office the riot office we can do another
show later on but it is built as a
fortress it's fortified I mean you
cannot I mean I get around really
zombie-proof from what they can see yeah
yeah so just go to the right on the
snacks telling everybody how many snacks
we have a board where we are let's make
up the obsession with post apocalyptic
stuff I love it like I love talking
about robots coming to get us and
zombies coming to get us and all this
stuff what do you think the human
fascination with like our own
destruction is all about well you're
you're into this like whole a I kick and
like how we're probably already in them
computer simulations yeah I mean like
that will happen I think we'll save that
for another show I think that people are
because Molly always kicks me out of the
table when I start talking about AI but
you know I think that people always want
to know how they're gonna die right and
this is the way that you can do it is to
be obsessed right is going to be an
asteroid or is going to be computers or
you know it's gonna be zombies so do
either of you have any hunches about how
you're gonna die
I just hope it's not on this show yeah
alien acknowledges that alien invasion
I feel like alien invasion would be a
good one yeah I know for certain it's
not in a plane crash which is the only
reason I don't like get terrified every
time I think it's gonna be old age like
slowly croak that's sort of how you want
to do it my final thought on this how
prepared are you guys for an actual
disaster forget let's pretend the
zombies and the aliens aren't I but you
factor that into your life like I'm big
on like I like having a lot of water
yeah I have a shitload of tuna like if
it goes down I'm gonna die of mercury
poisoning that's yeah I think about
earthquakes all the time being in
Southern California I'll be like lying
in battle big if an earthquake happened
right now which doorway would I run to
and like was the training I received an
elementary school sufficient to survive
it yes to that yeah but I really just
think about like surviving the initial
shock of that and not really what I'm
gonna do after I feel like I'm
self-sufficient I'd figure it out but
maybe I should be thinking more about
water and we have stockpiles of we have
a moat we have our motorcycle downstairs
to be honest which is like also the way
you get out of the city if there's an
earthquake or something so we're
prepared I like how you've prepared this
place for zombies and also a quick
escape yeah and there's a motorcycle
it's about thirty of there's a bottle of
whiskey somewhere too which is really
all part of why we moved to the office
away from the beach is in case of a
tsunami so now we're a couple miles off
last place we would've been screwed II
are you in a zombie proof bunker like
your whiskey and motorcycle ready let us
know in the comments right down below
gay people are soon gonna be able to
reproduce without members of the
opposite sex what's that sound that's
Rick Santorum's head exploding same-sex
couples may soon be able to have
children that are genetically related to
both parents dr. jacob hanna discovered
that it is entirely possible to use skin
stem cells from two adults to make a
human egg and human sperm cells the team
believes same-sex couples could seek
this treatment in as little as two years
however researchers did note that it
will be easier for two males to produce
a child as it is more complex to use two
women cells due to the Y chromosome all
right so the big argument that you
always hear from the anti-gay people is
well it can't be natural because they
can't procreate well here comes science
it's a beautiful thing right sorry yeah
but they're not gonna they're not
except science right oh yeah no they'll
come up with something else
yeah probably no this is such a
fascinating thing and such an exciting
thing for me I I get out a little bit
talking about like prenatal genetic
modifications and what that means
socially for us there was a book that
was required reading when I was in
coming as a freshman and it was called
the case against perfection written by
this guy Michael Sandel who's one of the
foremost living philosophers and he has
this whole case that you know we we all
want our kids to be as advantaged as
possible we pay for private schools we
pay for tutors we pay for the best
coaches
why wouldn't we if given the opportunity
or availability of Technology Prix net
prenatally choose genetics based on
what's gonna make them the most
advantaged yeah and the problem with
that becomes that you know maybe the
society becomes even more unequal than
it's ever been and all of that but this
is getting a little off track you I know
you're going to where he was it so this
is like a cross between like Gattaca and
a brave new world short I mean I think
that what we look if it's incredibly
exciting to see these advances happen in
science and I think it's incredible that
now families can really be complete in
this way it seems amazing but to me like
the advances that are happening in
science were happening so fast and so
radically that really it's the sky is
the limit for what is possible I mean
when you think about like what Molly's
talking about about really genetically
making your kids so that they can be
better at sports or better at finance or
be doctors or even rich or poor there's
genes for these things that are
determining and I I think it's an
incredibly exciting time to be alive
right now for what's possible for me
I've just wanted the wooly mammoth to
come back so I feel like if you can do
this you can bring the mammoths back you
want Jurassic Park well Jurassic world
is coming this summer so great I can't
wait this summer maybe it's possible as
but tear to your point a lot of this
though has to do with economics and I
think that's what people don't realize
that yes we're gonna have this super set
of people this 1% of people that will be
able to afford all these things and then
they're just gonna grow up with every
advantage and that's gonna separate the
1% from the 99% even more actually and I
think the more interesting question is
what makes us so uncomfortable morally
with the idea of being able to do that
prenatally versus postnatally like
there's no moral dilemma about oh go
send your kid to private school for most
people right that's interesting them
tutors when they're 2 years old on but
morally we get into this interesting
question of playing with like why is it
more why is it more unacceptable to
think about providing your kid with
those advantages before they're born
right these people just apply morals to
the primordial stew of yeah I think
friend has a company that's that's
growing diamonds.they culture these
diamonds mean they you know grow them
from a sliver of diamond and they're
impossible to tell a cultured diamond a
grown diamond from a real diamond you
cannot detect it or tell it with
microscopes with any sort of lasers with
anything and to me that's this
incredibly fascinating argument where
you say what is that what is the
difference now what is nature what is
grown in a laboratory I think we're
about to face it with all of this
synthetic meat that's about to come out
where people are growing all of our next
generation of hamburgers and hot dogs
are many many stories I'm obsessed with
that guy's stuff because I can't believe
that people died you're about to ask
these questions big ethical big moral
questions are starting to be coming to
play out you know it's what Elon must
just gave a lot of money to to put some
rules in place for AI because we're
gonna have to start governing things
that we never knew we needed to govern
in the past you knew he was gonna bring
it back to a totally short if you had
the option of picking between a set of
ten embryos for your child yeah are
there certain things that you would test
for make sure they don't have any
developmental or physical no these or
would you not want to know or would you
want the money if I had the money in the
means yeah do it yeah if I could make my
kid a great athlete and like be able to
dunk I wanted to dunk and I can't dunk
for a lot of us we look at you know
simple things like Alzheimer's you know
which is there's an easy way to detect
the genetics for that and I think that
you know many of us would would want to
choose our child so they don't have also
but I think there's a difference also
between the active and the passive
choosing right if you're just sorting
out for things that are developmental
problems right versus actively selecting
for like athleticism or
an eye color or hair color or maybe even
sexual preference at some point which
gets into a really interesting
conversation
yeah all right so then let's wrap this
up with the sexual preference part of
this the gay thing happened pretty quick
and by that I mean like the Wrights
thing this like these last five years
are you shocked at how quickly this has
happened like it's almost behind us and
I will be literally the happiest person
on earth when it's behind us because
gays just want equal rights not bonus
right I think that it's been incredibly
exciting just to see what's you know
it's like the old forest for the trees
thing I think it's been incredibly
exciting to see all of our social
advancements that we've had in the last
five years I mean it's been amazing
whether it's gay rights you know the
right to marry or whether it's been even
loosening of marijuana and drug laws
that you're seeing I mean we're lilly
Ledbetter Fair Pay Act well yeah I mean
we're we have an extremely long way to
go but I think that we're making
advances that we won't fully see until
we're looking back at a 10-year period
and go wow that was a that was a time
that that this country and the world
really stepped some leaps forward yeah
and what does it say in the Bible
something about gays being stoned which
an app for rich people who only want to
date rich people gingers new update is
for some people over thirty to shell out
nearly $20 a month for its premium
service but that's likely chump change
for the users of Luxy a new premium
dating app for rich people or as their
spokesperson put it it works a lot like
tinder except this is tinder - the poor
people in order to join the app men must
make at least 250,000 dollars a year and
must be verified with tax records while
women just have to be attractive all
right so men have to be rich women just
have to be attractive this feels really
gross to me yeah viscerally it really
upsets me but at the same time if
there's a market there's a market right
already there exists the right stuff
which is one that the only reason I know
it is my ex-boyfriends dad used it only
for Ivy Leaguers there's one that's just
for Harvard guys all about this guy
here's the thing people care about
different things in their mate and like
figure out what matters to you and then
find that and if you can like sort
through it really quickly then Who am I
to be like go
through a lot of other things right so
Molly's all for that so that I get it
but to her point so this is just
technology going to where people have
needs right if guys that have a lot of
money want to meet hot girls well then
there's an app for that but you also
know if you're that guy that you're just
meeting girls who are only wanting to
meet those rich guys anyway so it is a
there is a self selection process but
you know it's nice and then like JDate
or different than like what's called
like farmer's friends matters to you
then you're gonna a lot of farmers in
one very sore sheep sorry like anyway
people self-select on tinder for other
superficial sort more superficial things
even if they're tall if they're you know
white or black or whatever else if
they're you know fat or skinny or like
people self-select for that anyway it's
only a matter of time before like these
very nice dating sites get even more
niche and people like go for what they
know they like do you guys think we're
like taking something very important
very tangible out of the love equation
like where people used to maybe meet at
a bar not that that's the most loving
place on earth you would meet someone
just on a walk on a bike ride and now
it's like we have it all pre-selected
right do you think we're actually losing
something that's very human I mean I
think we're losing I think we're losing
something from all social media is right
now I mean all of our interactions on
how we're hanging with our friends it
all happens on Instagram and snapchat
and Twitter so yeah I mean we want
everybody to go outside and meet each
other and go to the library the kids go
to library anymore these days no yeah I
never understood the library your tummy
you just gonna give me a book and just
trust me that I'm gonna bring it back go
to the library without pretty much I
think that you know I don't know that
that we're necessarily losing things I
think we're just looking for things in
different places now right the friends
that I have that are with people that
they met online aren't in any less
loving or fulfilling relationships than
the ones who met in the real world you
know I think that certainly things are
changing whether or not normatively
that's good or bad it remains to be seen
but I I don't think I'm agnostic I don't
think that there is a that it is wrong
in
of itself to be finding some right so
it's sort of however you use it and
incorporate it into your life I'll go
with that
final thought on this how important is
your phone to your day-to-day life
because almost every story that we've
covered for the last two years is
somehow always related back to this
thing that we're walking around like how
important is that thing to you you know
I just had my phone we were together in
Haiti and I had my phone stolen and I
had two days without having a phone and
it was it was some of the best days of
my life I loved it so yeah my phone how
often did you go to your pocket in well
I go I go all the time and I've now have
a new role where the phone isn't in my
bedroom where the phone doesn't exist in
that place so at least there's no first
thing in the morning last thing at night
but I have to set a lot of rules for my
phone it's it's more boundaries and I
have my point about you your phone is
right there so I know it's like sort of
important I'm like itching don't touch
that thing
my boyfriend makes a joke that as soon
as they have phone implants for you that
I'm gonna be there for the first
customer of that because I'm always on
it according to him but yeah I am I mean
I think there's this certain certainly a
lack of separation between work and life
at least for us right because you're in
the startup world and you're you're
constantly feeling like your personal
brand and identity is linked with this
thing that you're building and for us
and Riots case it's an extra Keable in a
lot of ways and so the idea that you're
building the company from anywhere is
really exciting but it also means that
maybe you're not experiencing everywhere
right so you sort of gave us an excuse
that we can be on our alright well I
want to thank Molly and Bryn not only
for being the first guest on the Reuben
court but for bringing me and making me
home here at riot I'm extremely excited
so all the stories that we covered this
week we're all sourced from Riot org you
can see them in the links below and
that's where you can take the action and
we have a ton a ton of stuff coming up
for you guys
we got big celebrities we're gonna be
going out in the field more we're gonna
be bringing some interesting new people
and here anything else that I might be
forgetting
there's gonna be ways to take action and
there's gonna be a lot of ways to take
mutant and also that final thought that
you're gonna bring us home on right
we're gonna have birthday parties for
everybody birthday parties for everybody
alright thanks for watching guys we'll
do it again